[Musica]
eccomi sono in quarantena ma soltanto
perché ho avuto degli amici poco
prudenti spero che riuscirò lo stesso
raccontarvi questa storia che trovo
abbastanza appassionante però vorrei
cominciare facendo che una domanda una
domanda retorica cioè secondo voi
l'italia il paese ricco un paese povero
vi posso rispondere già direttamente io
è un paese ricco ma abitato da poveri e
il motivo è in cui il disegnino che
forse vedete accanto a me la montagna
più alta che io ho paragonato al k2 è la
ricchezza privata delle famiglie
italiane la montagnetta piccola vicino
che io ho scelto il monte pisanino nelle
alpi apuane quello è il nostro debito
pubblico
e se passiamo alla slide successiva vi
faccio vedere come è divisa questa
ricchezza allora la ricchezza privata in
italia è grosso modo 10 mila miliardi il
debito pubblico è grosso modo i 2.000
miliardi poi però questa ricchezza non è
divisa equamente in nessuna parte del
mondo la ricchezza di ritrattamento e in
italia divisa questi sono dati
dell'istat è diviso per famiglie le
famiglie ricche come vedete sono quelle
poi famiglie molto ricche famiglie
povere famiglie molto povere ma
ripeto qual è il problema il problema
esattamente questo che la ricchezza non
essendo divisa equamente crea i ricchi
ei poveri e la ricchezza e hanno sentito
i precedenti relatori ne hanno parlato
lungamente la ricchezza è qualcosa che
si può ereditare si può sposate si può
rubare ma diciamo che fondamentalmente
il denaro bisognerebbe guadagnarlo
lavorando col sudore della salute come
come diceva la bibbia allora vediamo
come alla slide ancora successiva ecco
qui abbiamo più o meno un quadro di
diciamo degli stipendi un quadro degli
stipendi in italia allora c'è uno
stipendio medio come vedete è molto
basso
poi c'è una pensione media anche quella
molto basso poi c'è una soglia di
povertà che poi ci verremo ci torneremo
sopra
se voi siete sotto quella cifra li vede
temi poco più di mille euro siete poveri
poi vediamo gli stipendi dei ministri e
parlamentari lo sappiamo e poi vediamo
la retribuzione lorda mensile indice un
top manager e quindi questo già c da c
da un po l'idea nodi che cosa sono i
ricchi e poveri e di come divisa questa
ricchezza però andando avanti
tutti sappiamo più o meno di finire chi
sono i ricchi ei poveri invece sono più
difficili da definire ancora l'istat io
l'ho tradotto in un disegnino che forse
rende l'idea più delle tabelle l'istat
queste sono le cifre
anche l'istat usa le classifiche abcd è
assolutamente povero appena povero quasi
povero non povero però vedete l'estero e
non poveri praticamente siete sempre
sullo stipendio
sono cifre molto vicine queste due no
che io adesso le indico malamente perché
sono a casa davanti allo schermo di un
computer
comunque le soglie sono tutte molto
simili quindi questo è il paese dei
poveri è però vediamo andiamo ancora
avanti un momento allora i poveri chi
sono esattamente
chi sono i più poveri tra i poveri i
mendicanti i precari i disoccupati i
vecchi i giovani
tutte le risposte esatte però c'è una
categoria che trasversale a tutte queste
qua che le tocca tutte diciamo ed è
esattamente questo non è un paese per
donne titolava un quotidiano la stampa
qualche giorno fa era una lunga
inchiesta proprio sui temi di cui stiamo
parlando stasera e
perché
perché le donne sono le più povere dei
poveri cioè l'oscar della povertà
aspetta le donne perché le donne
precarie guadagnano meno di un uomo
precario le pensionate guadagnano meno
di un pensionato le immigrate guadagnano
meno di un uomo immigrato inoltre ci
sono delle sottocategorie molto
preoccupanti perché se una donna ha
figli è più povera di una donna che non
ha figli se una donna ha figli e ai
genitori anziani è più povera di una
donna orfana e single e così via
naturalmente
diciamo che per cavarsela in italia
bisogna essere single orfani senza figli
naturalmente è ovviamente bisogna essere
maschi questo fenomeno e andiamo
ve lo spiego si chiama gender pay gap
vuol dire differenza retributiva ecco
qui ve lo ha sintetizzato le donne
guadagnano in media il 20 per cento meno
di un uomo per ogni 100 euro guadagnati
da un uomo una donna ne guadagna 80
l'onu lo ha definito il più grande furto
della storia però è è un furto assai
poco conosciuto guardate in quest'altra
in italia per lo meno che negli altri
paesi se ne parla molto di più guardate
quest'altra
quest'altra foto slide ecco questo è il
manifesto di una campagna americana
contro le differenze retributive di
genere e la scritta significa molto
semplicemente donne come un uomo ma meno
costose insomma e ho preso come esempio
l'america perché non solo il paese dove
diciamo innato il femminismo ma è anche
un paese dove si fa molta attenzione al
rapporto tra lavoro e retribuzione negli
stati uniti le persone parlano
liberamente
del loro stipendio delle loro buste paga
e si chiede quanto guadagni si dice io
guadagno todt e quindi è un paese dove
diciamo c'è c'è più trasparenza rispetto
a questo problema in italia invece come
sappiamo molto maleducato chiedere
scusa tu quanto guadagnino per me lo
chiedo lo dico assolutamente che ti
importa
diciamo che questo purtroppo
contribuisce a creare il problema
tenete conto che in italia una donna
praticamente comincia a guadagnare
soltanto a fine febbraio i precedenti
due mesi è come se avesse lavorato
gratis adesso oggi cos'è il 10 per cui
ecco tra poco produce remo a guadagnare
no rispetto a un uomo sempre e cosa si
può fare per rimediare
non è che la gente nel mondo non se ne
sia mai occupato per esempio guardiamo
quest'altra quest'altra foto ecco questo
è un tweet che ha fatto barack obama ex
presidente degli stati uniti lo ha fatto
qualche giorno fa a fine gennaio in
questo tweet lui ricorda la firma della
sua prima legge da presidente degli
stati uniti parliamo del 2009 e quindi
appunto 13 anni fa era esattamente una
legge per la parità salariale e prende
il nome da una femminista americana che
ha fatto una grandissima battaglia
proprio per ottenere questa legge
benissimo allora questa legge è di 13
anni fa dopo di che la situazione è
migliorata vediamo una prossima foto
questo è un
graphic piccolo grafico disegnino che ha
fatto l'ufficio del lavoro americano
come vedete per un uomo fu un uomo
guadagna un dollaro una donna a 74
centesimi quindi evidentemente non è non
è servita ancora la legge malgrado ci
sia appunto abbattere questo questo
problema ma perché questo problema e
così
pesante beh è pesante perché si porta
dietro una concatenazione di altri
problemi per esempio le donne al lavoro
allora le donne come noto sono più
preparate più
dati ufficiali per ogni 10 laureati sei
sono donne però guarda caso per ogni 100
occupati solo 49 sono donne no è uno dei
motivi per cui ci sono poche donne sul
mercato del lavoro in italia e anche
questo che sono pagate troppo poco per
cui che cosa succede che quando in una
famiglia
si crea un problema
organizzativo per esempio adesso c'è
stato il problema del covi di bambini in
da tutta nei suoi problemi simili però
in realtà questo capita sempre quando si
deve decidere di rinunciare uno
stipendio perché uno dei due deve stare
a casa per risolvere appunto dei
problemi di gestione familiare a quale
stipendio si rinuncia ovviamente lo
stipendio più basso che è sempre quello
della donna inevitabilmente no tra
l'altro se per caso lo stipendio della
donna invece più alto diciamo che il
genere i mariti non sono felicissimi di
questo
e quindi che cosa succede che le donne
sono pagati meno anche per un altro
motivo che alle donne viene nel scusate
io spesso mi rendo conto che sto
guardando per aria però è difficile
parlare non vedendovi ecco e le donne
sono spesso sottoposte al part time
obbligatorio
questo capita
diciamo nell 80 per cento dei casi
mentre gli uomini capita solo nel 30 per
cento dei casi un part time significa
uno stipendio più basso quindi significa
contributi più bassi e quindi significa
che poi avremo una pensione più bassa e
questo spiega perché una pensionata
donna ha una pensione più bassa è più
povera di impressionato l'uomo allora si
dirà ma perlomeno le donne fanno figli
visto che non lavorano no neanche quello
perché se disgraziatamente fanno figli
la loro possibilità di lavorare di fare
carriera si riduce di un altro 25 per
cento per cui abbiamo questo comma 22
che questo è tutto molto italiano per
cui le donne finisce che non lavora e
non riescono neanche a fare figli cioè
ci sono delle cose che a me che io trovo
girando sui soprattutto sui sui siti
dell'istat dove è pieno di queste
informazioni che poi ovviamente vanno
decodificate perché se non sono grafici
i numeri non si capisce niente per
esempio sapete che solo la metà delle
donne italiane ha un conto corrente
personale
le altre ben che vada ce l'hanno in
comune col marito oppure sapete che il
30 per cento delle donne italiane adulte
non parlo delle ragazzine o delle
adolescenti che quello è ovvio le donne
adulte il 30 per cento dipende
economicamente in tutto e per tutto da
un uomo che può essere il padre o il
marito però non ha nessuna autonomia
praticamente deve chiedere la paghetta
e a proposito di paghetta sapete che ai
ragazzini maschi la paghetta viene data
in automatico cioè loro hanno un giorno
a settimana in cui genitori danno loro
paghetta che può essere poco tanto ma
non sanno che quel giorno invece alle
ragazzine femmine la paghetta viene
erogata a discrezione dei genitori
beh vediamo adesso se sarai buona ti do
la paghetta se nostra settimana non te
la doppia e quindi già da piccole ci si
abitua a questa dipendenza ma ci sono
anche altre cose sapete che l'evasore
maschio cioè l'evasore tipo scusatemi è
maschio e di mezza età questo perché
perché le donne sono più oneste
certo probabilmente ma soprattutto
perché le donne hanno meno gestione di
soldi hanno meno soldi e quindi hanno
meno la diciamo tentazione di evadere il
fisco e non solo sapete che la
corruzione è praticamente riguarda
esclusivamente maschi vedo che sta
andando lunga cerco di accelerare di
quando esclusivamente i maschi perché le
donne non avendo nessun potere e nessuno
cerca neanche ricomprarsela capito per
cui siamo povere anche di fronte alla
corruzione abbiamo visto negli stati
uniti si sta cercando di fare qualcosa
in italia anche vediamo un'altra slide
così via legge circa un po da questa
chiacchiera ecco questa è una legge più
o meno simile a quella americana che
entrata è stata approvata a fine ottobre
in italia
questo è il trito della parlamentare che
l'ha portata che l'ha portata
all'approvazione
adesso vediamo se questa legge sulla
parità salariale e sarà più efficace
anche quella degli stati uniti che dopo
13 anni come abbiamo visto ancora sta
per aria se non ci sono altri modi
andiamo un'altra foto c'è un altro modo
per ottenere una retribuzione adeguata e
questo caso qua è un tipico di nella
sera di qualche giorno fa è una top
manager ha scoperto di essere pagata
meno dei suoi colleghi maschi ha fatto
causa e ha ottenuto che il tribunale
delle regione e le facesse avere questo
discreto rimborso per i disagi subiti
però vi sembra giusto cioè è normale che
dobbiamo rivolgerci al tribunale per
essere pagate il giusto perché lo dice
anche la costituzione vediamo l'ultimo
l'ultimo cartello la costituzione dice
il lavoratore ha diritto ad una
retribuzione proporzionata alla quantità
e qualità del suo lavoro
attenzione che cosa dice dice il
lavoratore non dice la lavoratrice
questo perchè la costituzione è stata
scritta 70 anni fa 70 anni fa le donne
al lavoro erano decisamente ancora meno
di oggi poi non c'era ancora l'abitudine
alle desinenze no e quindi insomma dice
solo il lavoratore però sono passati 70
anni è possibile che ancora non siamo
riusciti a ottenere questa parità sia
nell'accesso al lavoro sia soprattutto
nelle retribuzioni che uno dei freni per
l'accesso al lavoro io adesso non voglio
fare i predicozzi a nessuno però io
credo che si possa fare qualcosa per
rimediare a questa situazione
per esempio le aziende dovrebbero
imparare a retribuire le persone sulla
base del loro valore del loro lavoro non
soltanto non fare distinzioni di genere
le donne stesse dovrebbero fare qualcosa
dovrebbero acquisire una maggiore
consapevolezza dovrebbero non
vergognarsi di chiedere di avere una
retribuzione adeguata e gli uomini forse
dovrebbero imparare che non
necessariamente dobbiamo avere la
paghetta perché non sempre abbiamo un
marito un padre
che ci supporta abbiamo diritto diciamo
a una totale indipendenza economica
poi vorrei dirvi quali sono le strade
migliori per uscire da questo gap però
ovviamente non le so se sapessi
probabilmente è stata il presidente
della repubblica che magari mi darebbero
un appannaggio minore di quello che
spetta un presidente maschio però ecco
quello che voglio dirvi secondo me
questo problema che non è assolutamente
conosciuto quando io ne vado a parlare
in giro mi dicono no dai non è vero
allora io vi dico
parlatene patate nei vostri luoghi di
lavoro confrontatevi con il vostro
collega con la vostra collega cerca di
capire se davvero guadagnate uguale
e poi non mi sto dicendo di fare la
rivoluzione però di prendere
consapevolezza di questo perché io credo
che parlare di un problema sia il modo
migliore prima o poi per risolverlo
questo anche per i nostri figli che
magari impareranno di
impareranno il modo di farsi pagare
tutti uguali
ho finito
[Applauso]